hello I'm Adina Jones I was actually
married in July so we're working on that
that name chasing it's like the hardest
thing ever so in an an I work at
bleacher report and the deputy managing
editor their editor there and in an
effort to get ready for this event I did
what any great journalist would do I
procrastinated I learned the lyrics to
cardi B's bar da cardi I got in not one
but two fights with my husband my even
research one of those like really swaggy
rehab facilities in upstate New York
where like rich women go just to get
away from the world because you know
they're just they're just tired because
let me tell you something I am tied I'm
tied I'm not like I didn't get eight
hours of sleep last night tired or I did
have enough vegetables in my diet tired
I'm like fannie lou hamer sick and tired
of being sick inside I'm sick and tired
of the microaggressions um we you're
just not a good fit for the team
you know just the cultural fit I feel
threatened when you speak to me can I
touch your hair what is the URL for
black Twitter I'm tired I'm tired of the
judgments you look like you could a
dude up like you lift right or I bet you
had athletic scholarship to school right
you definitely did I'm also tired of the
judgments the random judgments the 10
things every woman in their 30 should
know I only know two and a half of
these okay and I'm also women with
bigger but should be more intelligent
well I should be a Rhodes Scholar with
all the the educational background I got
going on in here
so you know what it is what I'm
realizing why I'm tired I'm life is
happening to me and I'm letting it like
judo chop me in the throat I saw some
grandpa's from an influencer selling
flat tummy tea and I was like life is
10% of what happens to you in 90% of how
you react to it has shock fits bow
hashtag love and light hashtag hashtag
hashtag and you know I was like actually
I'm feeling what this person is saying
you know I'm I'm moving too fast you
know I'm I'm always trying to be the
best never settling for less striving
just leaving it all out on the floor
every day
that's why but how was it me me a strong
black woman me the product of a
sharecroppers son from North Carolina
letting this affect me how is it me the
product of a bougie black woman with a
biology holding degree that will cut you
in her finest fur how is it that I'm
letting this affect me like I said I'm
moving too fast a quick jog on my memory
will hi remember the first time that I
just left it all on the floor
so my shirt says from Brooklyn but my
mom did me the favor and moved me out to
Brent were in high school for a better
education at some point in time and I
ran for senior class president and I was
gonna win this year the only problem was
I lost every other year every damn year
I ran for class president I lost but
this year was going to be different I
was gonna give them Obama change they
could believe in they didn't know what
they were in for I was pulling out all
the stops fliers was my name on it and
endorsements when the popular kids check
buttons with my face on it check poster
boards in every hallway check and was we
doing a cupcake giveaways at the end of
every class period hell yeah we were
doing that check so that my piece de
resistance what it was is I had a group
of the sassiest chicks at Brown when
high school had to offer
they were my campaign team and yeah I
know right campaign team you know and I
had a girl from every walks of life we
had the funny girl the popular girl the
I do recreational drugs girl the I'm
from Queens and so that means I'm
better than all you Long Island girls
and every Wednesday
it was campaign day we wore t-shirts red
and white baseball tees that shout out
to my dad for getting them for free 99
and my mom for helping me bring them to
school and there on the front they said
you know you want to and on the back and
said vote for Edina so yeah I wasn't we
were going hard every Wednesday we
preached the gospel of how great a dina
was going to be we were gonna do
principal for a day we were gonna do
school trips to Six Flags
you're gonna air your grievances to the
administration it was on we were gonna
leave everything on the floor if I lost
this year it wasn't because of what I
didn't do it's because of what they
didn't do we were leaving it all on the
floor everybody voted in their eighth
period government class I fought like to
the to my school bus I was like yeah I
got this
we want this we left it all on the floor
it's what we do get on a school bus kids
are like hey you vote today they talking
each other yeah I voted today who did
you vote for I didn't vote for that Dina
girl she's stuck up Wow like since when
did representing yourself become stuck
up since when did doing any and
everything you could do to win become
stuck up no actually they they were
wrong they were just outliers in the sea
of yes votes for Edina next day homeroom
is where we announced the winner after
all the mundane announcements track
practice pools closed all that stuff we
got to the announcement for senior class
president and your two thousand was
three two thousand three senior class
president is not Adina nice those are
just an eighth of the emotions I felt
running through my body twenty kids my
whole room staring at the back of my
neck I know they wait for me to react
you know what not gonna react instead
I'm gonna go to my locker and cry on the
phone with my mom
just talk about how stupid everybody was
I I I'm not any actually sure when I got
out when I got over the loss of my
election honestly I'm probably still
salty about it congratulations to mark
Parker he won and but the one thing that
I did rest easy with was that I did
everything I could right
I did everything I could if I go back
today I wouldn't change it for the world
I left it all out on the floor and
honestly it's kind of how I live my
daily life sometimes to my detriment
because when you go out a hundred what
do you have left but that's me every day
in every moment I'm just there trying to
prove trying to grow trying to live you
best believe if I'm in a room with you
you're going to get the best of me and
I'm gonna take every single piece of
juice I can squeeze out of that moment
but the fact is that as I grow I'm
learning not I'm leaving it all on the
floor but I'm not leaving my self-worth
I'm not leaving my sanity that's the
biggest thing I'm learning to self-care
self-care means untime runs in the park
self-care means deep conditioning and
detangling my new natural hair self-care
means bottles of rose a self-care
sometimes it just means staring at the
clouds you know so I'm always gonna be
that girl that woman who goes a hundred
percent and a hundred miles per hour but
I'm always gonna continue to learn to
give myself grace in those quiet moments
in the locker room and I hope you do the
same thank you
you